la dernière fois j'ai cherché à vous
convaincre que le levier d'action le
plus efficace pour lutter contre le
changement climatique était sans doute
de rendre liées à de youtube bénéfique
pour que celle-ci promeuvent davantage
des vidéos de sensibilisation aux
risques et aux solutions contre le
changement climatique plutôt que des
vidéos climato sceptiques ou des
publicités de 4,4 et de viande de boeuf
et il est tentant de penser que la
difficulté de ce projet réside surtout
dans le fait de convaincre youtube de
rendre son ia bénéfique à n'en pas
douter il s'agit d'une sacrée difficulté
mais à mon sens il ne s'agit même pas de
la plus grosse difficulté est de très
loin
en effet trouver des solutions
algorithmique pour rendre cette ia
robustement bénéfique me semble beaucoup
plus dure encore
faisons une expérience de pensée
imaginons nous à la place de youtube et
imaginons que l'on veuille prendre notre
ya bénéfique
comment faire pour y arriver de manière
fiable robuste et efficace
comment rendre les ja robustement
bénéfique pour toute l'humanité
pour commencer et contrairement à ce
qu'on pourrait croire naïvement il ne
suffit pas d'installer des boutons
d'arrêt d'urgence pour stopper les ja
qui ne serait pas bénéfique
en effet même si on avait un tel bouton
pour l'ia de youtube rien ne dit qu'un
humain la purée au bon moment non
seulement parce qu'il est très difficile
de déterminer s'il y a de youtube est
globalement bénéfique ou non mais aussi
et surtout parce qu'arrêter soudainement
l'ia de youtube aurait certainement de
nombreuses conséquences indésirables
de façon plus générale quand une ia et
performante on a tendance à lui faire
confiance et à saluer davantage dessus
ce qui nous rend dépendants tél et là je
ne parle pas de science fiction
je parle des nombreuses à d'aujourd'hui
qu'elle soit utilisée pour améliorer
l'expérience utilisateur des internautes
gérer les réseaux électriques en temps
réel ou fluidifier les marchés
financiers et ça ça risque d'être encore
plus le cas dans le futur notamment par
exemple quand les voitures autonomes
nous mènerons de a à b et que l'on
s'endormira au volant le bouton d'arrêt
d'urgence serait alors en aucun cas une
garantie de sécurité
mais il ne s'agit là que d'une
difficulté parmi tant d'autres dans la
tâche de rendre les ja bénéfique
une autre difficulté majeure est le fait
que rendre satire bénéfique ne doit pas
être trop contraignant pour li à elle
même en effet si on exige d'eux il ya
qu'elle satisfasse tous les critères de
tous les citoyens français
alors les ya risque fort de se retrouver
complètement paralysé et incapable de
faire quoi que ce soit de telles mesures
risquent fort d'être rejetés d'emblée
les entreprises du numérique et si
jamais on arrivait à imposer de telles
réglementations dans un territoire donné
comme la france il y à fort à parier que
d'autres pays en compétition économique
n'accepterait pas d' imposer ces
réglementations ceux qui rendraient les
ya développé en france insignifiante sur
le long terme
bref quand il s'agit de rendre les ja
bénéfique il est primordial de ne pas
trop empiéter sur les performances désir
d'une certaine manière il faut piloter
les îliens sont les freiner une
troisième difficulté majeure qui se
posent quand on cherche à rendre les ir
bénéfique est une difficulté dont on a
longuement parlé sur scène son rôle à
savoir la robustesse de saisir non
seulement à des attaques de malfaiteurs
mais aussi et surtout à des attaques
détient elle même et comme on l'a vu
dans les épisodes 39 et 40
il s'agit là d'une difficulté majeure
qui n'ont trivial à résoudre qui ne
concerne d'ailleurs pas que les ja que
l'on cherche à rendre bénéfique
enfin la quatrième est possiblement plus
grande difficulté à laquelle on va
devoir faire face c'est que l'on sera
quasi sûrement en profond désaccord sur
les valeurs a programmé dans les ya des
générations de philosophes ne semble
avoir fait qu'amplifier les divergences
sur les bonnes approches à avoir de la
philosophie morale et même des
intellectuels d'aujourd'hui se battent
comme des hooligans sur les réseaux
sociaux
nous ne sommes pas d'accord sur les
morales a programmé et nous ne seront
probablement jamais d'accord pourtant si
on en croit l'épisode précédent il ya
urgence à programmer des valeurs morales
dans les il ya aujourd'hui
aussi bizarre que ça puisse sembler il
va nous falloir nous mettre d'accord sur
quelles valeurs programmes et même si
nous sommes en profond désaccord sur
quelles valeurs programmé toutes ces
difficultés font que rendre lié à
bénéfique est sans doute aujourd'hui
l'un des plus grands défis que
l'humanité n'ait jamais rencontré selon
le philosophe nick bostrom il s'agit
même d'un défi digne des plus grands
talents mathématiques de la prochaine
génération
sauf que vu l' influence d i had
aujourd'hui j'ai bien peur qu attendre
la prochaine génération soit immoral si
on prend au sérieux les épisodes 29 et
52 programme et les valeurs des ja est
un problème auquel devrait s'atteler les
talents mathématiques d'aujourd'hui et
il ya quelques mois après des années de
réflexion j'ai fini par prendre ses
arguments au sérieux et j'en suis arrivé
à la même conclusion
j'ai conclu qu'il était temps que je
m'intéresse de très près à cette
question et j'ai aussi été très déçu
très déçu d'avoir le sentiment d'être
presque seul à prendre cette question au
sérieux
j'ai donc cherché à compiler toutes les
informations pertinentes à la
programmation des valeurs a essayé
d'être aussi clair que possible dans mes
explications et a essayé de guider toute
personne qui pourrait s'intéresser à la
question pour qu'elles déterminent
comment elle peut contribuer au mieux
aux défis de la programmation des
valeurs et ça m'a conduit à écrire cet
article
si le bien de l'humanité vous semble une
question importante je vous recommande
très vivement de lire cet article
surtout si vous avez certaine aisance
mathématiques mais même si les maths ce
n'est pas trop votre truc
ce document contient énormément de
réflexion très abordable et très contre
intuitive ainsi que des suggestions de
bonnes actions à prendre pour aider à
rendre les ja bénéfique sans avoir à
contribuer à la recherche sur la
programmation des valeurs vraiment
j'insiste encore dessus je pense que ce
document est le truc le plus important
que j'aurais écrit dans toute ma vie je
pense ni plus ni moins que le futur de
l'humanité est en jeu dans le reste de
cette vidéo je vais développer la partie
technique de cet article l'idée n'est
pas de résoudre directement la
programmation des valeurs qui me semble
bien trop compliquée pour être résolu en
20 pages
l'idée est de structurer notre réflexion
et d'identifier les étapes clés pour
rendre les ja robustement bénéfique et
par souci pédagogique
j'ai identifié cinq étapes incarné par
cinq personnages fictifs appelé alice
bob charlie day et erin de façon
grossière erin sera en charge de la
collecte des données d de l'inférence de
l'état du monde à partir des données
charlie de calculer les valeurs morales
des différents états du monde bob de
concevoir un circuit de la récompense
qui donnent à l'iss les bulls incentives
et ali sera en charge d'entreprendre les
actions pour améliorer l'état du monde
alors ça peut paraître assez compliqué
d'introduire tous ces personnages mais
il me semble en fait crucial de penser
le problème dont toute son intégralité
plutôt que de chercher à avoir des
solutions locales dont on a du mal à
anticiper les conséquences globales
arrêtons nous d'abord sur alice
aujourd'hui et probablement demain les
ja les plus performantes dans la prise
de décision sont celles développées dans
le cadre de l'apprentissage par
renforcement ou reinforcement learning
dont on apparaît dans l'épisode 36 cia
cherche à maximiser des récompenses à
venir qui leur seront données en
fonction de l'état du monde futur voilà
qui pose déjà de nombreux défis comme
par exemple le dilemme exploration
versus exploitation vaut-il mieux
entreprendre des actions dont on est
quasi sûr qu'elles seront bénéfiques ou
vaut-il mieux tenter des expériences
pour mieux comprendre les actions
possibles et leurs conséquences et ainsi
potentiellement déterminer des actions
formidablement plus bénéfique que celle
que l'on connaît jusque là en
particulier peut on quantifier les
risques associés à tenter telle ou telle
expérience
il s'agit là de questions triviales et
de nombreux défis associés à
l'exploration sur ont d'ailleurs déjà
été énoncée par exemple dans un article
intitulé can't quit problème soit
effective ok ça c'est alice mais pour
quelle liste prennent de bonnes
décisions
encore faut-il qu'elles sachent quel est
l'état du monde est clairement pour y
arriver lui faut des données du monde
alors de nouveaux joueurs par chance il
ya une quantité monumentale de données
accessible sur internet alice pourra
certainement exploiter ces données pour
mieux comprendre le monde qui l'entouré
cependant sur internet il y a du bon et
il ya aussi du moins bon
dès lors il sera important de disposer
de données dont on peut certifier la
fiabilité
tel est le job dherin et rennes sera en
charge non seulement de la collecte de
données mais aussi de la certification
et de la traçabilité des données et il
ya de bonnes chances que des
technologies comme la belote chine soit
d'une grande utilité pour y arriver
ok mais même étant donné des données
fiables déterminer l'état du monde
à partir de ces données n'est pas une
tâche facile en effet les données
prélevées sont souvent des données
faciles à prélever
il faut donc s'attendre à ce qu'il y ait
des normes biais de sélection dans la
collecte des données ne pas tomber dans
le piège de confondre corrélation et
causalité et le job de dave le job de
dave c'est d'inférer les états du monde
probable étant donné les données
collectées et ça peut sembler être une
tâche assez impossible mais pour un bail
vient ceci ne correspond en fait qu'un
simple calcul à savoir celui de la
formule deux pays mais le problème c'est
bien sûr que la formule de bèze et
horriblement longue à calculer y compris
avec des machines
il faut donc que des gens fassent des
calculs approximativement bayésiens à
l'instar des méta régression bayésienne
utilisé par l' oms pour un ferrer les
maladies les plus létale dans le monde
comme l'expliquent risque alpha dans
cette vidéo le job day soulève encore
bien d'autres difficultés
mais passons les sous silence paul
heures imaginons que dave a réussi à
déterminer l'état du monde pour calice
sache quoi faire
lui faut connaître la désirabilité de
tel ou tel état du monde
tel est le job de charlie puis arriva
devoir se doter de la faculté de donner
un score à tel ou tel état du monde
et si possible de faire en sorte que ces
valeurs correspondent
à des valeurs mais ceci dit il sera
certainement souhaitable que ces valeurs
ne soit pas directement des valeurs des
humains d'aujourd'hui car les valeurs
des humains d'aujourd'hui sont souvent
très problématique
elles sont souvent bancal infondées
incohérente lunatique et mal informés
elles sont souvent des convictions
orpheline c'est à dire des conséquences
de modèles de penser que ceux qui
possèdent ces convictions ont pourtant
eux mêmes déjà rejeté depuis bien
longtemps et je vous conseille vivement
cette superbe vidéo de jules haag élèves
pour en savoir plus sur ce concept
en fait si on devait faire un vote
démocratique internationale aujourd'hui
sur les valeurs à programmer il ya fort
à parier que la xénophobie et les
préjugés racistes sexistes ou homophobes
domine est que les questions
environnementales soient négligés les
valeurs des humains d'aujourd'hui semble
assez fallacieuses et du coup ça semble
assez problématique de les implémenter
directement et d'ailleurs je parle des
humains en général je pourrais
longuement parlé de moi en particulier
mes convictions morales n'ont cessé
d'être bouleversée au cours des
dernières années si bien que je suis
convaincu que si une ia suivais mes
valeurs morales d'aujourd'hui le mois
dans un an serait terrifiée par cette ia
en fait je suis terrifiée dès
aujourd'hui à l'idée qu'une ya ceux
conformes aux valeurs morales du mois
aujourd'hui les valeurs morales d'unia
se doivent en un sens d'être meilleur
que les valeurs des humains
d'aujourd'hui dans l'article je propose
typiquement qu'elle correspondait
davantage à ce qu'on voudrait vouloir
qu'à ce que l'on veut nous encore il
faudrait que ce soit ce qu'on voudrait
vouloir si on réfléchit c'est bien mieux
et si on était bien mieux informés bref
je propose des idées du mois + + et de
la pollution cohérente
extrapolé dont on apparaît dans
l'épisode 38 et enfin le dernier maillon
de cette chaîne le plus important je
pense et bob le rôle de bob et de
concevoir le circuit de la récompense
d'alice en cherchant notamment à
garantir que le fait qu alice n'aura pas
intérêt à hacker son circuit de la
récompense
il s'agit là d'une tâche extrêmement
ardue à laquelle je n'ai pas de bonne
solution mais intuitivement bob
correspond à cette petite voix en nous
qui prend du recul sur nos actions et
cherche à nous guider vers ce qu'on
voudrait vouloir plutôt que nous les ccd
à nos désirs passagers et comme on en a
longuement parlé tout au long de
l'action
14 bob veille en particulier à mettre en
place des neiges pour que même quand on
agit sans réfléchir on fasse néanmoins
ce qu'on voudrait vouloir
or voilà qu'il raisonne d'ailleurs pas
mal avec le concept de moi pdg et de moi
travailleurs dont jules agalev parle
dans cette vidéo
donc j'ai déjà entendu si typique
devrait parler dans l'un de ces podcasts
l'idée est que bob est une sorte de moi
pdg qui prend du recul et est capable de
changer brutalement de direction dans le
comportement du mois mais moi pdg et
coûteux il doit croiser beaucoup
d'informations réfléchir longuement et
est constamment hésitant bien souvent il
vaut mieux s'affairer à la tâche et un
peu oublier le recul qui est pourtant
nécessaire
c'est ce que fait alice elle fait des
actions pour maximiser ses récompenses
sans se demander si ces récompenses sont
en effet les récompenses qu'il faudrait
maximiser et bien le rôle de bob est une
sorte de rôle de pdg
il doit surveiller que tout le circuit
de la récompense fonctionne bien
karine collecte et certifie correctement
ces données que dave effectué des
approximations crédible de la formule de
base est que charlie calcul des valeurs
qui ont de bonnes chances d'être ce que
la plupart des humains voudrait vouloir
et bob doit ajuster les récompenses a
attribué à alice en fonction de tous ces
calculs complexes en particulier il est
crucial que bob garde le contrôle
d'alice et kaliste n'arrive pas ou n'est
pas intérêt à hacker bob
sauf que bien sûr tout ce que bob peut
faire pour y arriver c'est injuste et
les récompenses d'alice il semble
désirable que bob charge typiquement a
exigé d'alice qu'elle garantisse la
supériorité cognitif de bob sur alice
bref si je récapitule donc erin doit
collecter et certifier les données dave
doit inférées les états probable du
monde
charlie doit déterminer des scores ou
voudraient vouloir attribuer à ces
différents états du monde et alice doit
prendre des décisions qui sont conformes
aux récompenses promises par bob l
architecture globale que je propose pour
les ir que l'on cherchera à rendre
robustement bénéfique dans mon article
et il me semble que penser selon cette
architecture est utile mais je pense
aussi fortement que cette architecture
est en fait mauvaise qu'elle est
inadéquate et très incomplète après tout
je sais que je n'ai pas suffisamment
réfléchi à ce problème et j'espère bien
que les plus grands talents parmi vous
corrigeront mais brouillon approximatif
de sorte à se rapprocher d'une solution
robuste pour rendre les ja bénéfique
ce n'est qu'à cette condition que je me
sentirai enfin rassuré quant au futur de
l'humanité
la nar fois je vous ai parlé de
changements climatiques et notamment
j'avais essayé d'insister sur le fait
que si on pensait que c'était une
urgence
l urgence et que la vie de millions de
centaines de millions peut-être même
deux milliards d'humains était vraiment
en jeu alors si on se donnait cet
objectif il me semble que la meilleure
façon de l'atteindre et de d'avoir un
impact vraiment important c'était de
passer par une modification de
l'algorithme de youtube qui arrêterait
de recommander les vidéos selon une
logique de maximisation de la rétention
des utilisateurs mais qui chercheraient
également inclure dans son objectif
par exemple la promotion de vidéos a
plus intelligente bienveillante et qui
faisait davantage réfléchir et il y en a
beaucoup parmi vous qui ne semble pas
avoir fait l'effort de faire cette
expérience de pensée que je propose est
dans la vidéo précédente
aussi ce vraiment imaginer qu'il s'agit
d'un problème vraiment urgent que le
changement climatique est lu énormément
de commentaires suite à vidéo précédente
qui ne correspondaient pas à cette
expérience de pensée et qui me reprocher
par exemple de mettre en avant mes
valeurs politiques ou autres et qu'ils
essaient du coup entendre que la vidéo
précédente n'était que de l'idéologie et
ne correspondait pas du tout à une
question scientifique ou prédictive en
fait faut bien voir qu'une fois qu'on a
fixé un objectif neuf fois qu'on a c'est
vraiment dit tel est l'objectif que l'on
se fixe la question de comment atteindre
cet objectif au mieux est une question
qui devient alors une question de
prédiction c'est une question de
détermination des actions qui conduiront
aux meilleurs conséquence et ça c'est
une question vraiment prédictive et du
coup si on prend juste cette question en
compte ce que je disais dans la vidéo
précédente c'est que il me semble
vraiment que passer paraguay youtube
était la meilleure façon d'atteindre
l'objectif qu'on s'était fixés par bien
sûr si on n'accepte pas cette prémisse
l'importance du changement climatique
alors les conclusions de la vidéo
précédente ne tiennent pas et c'est
parfaitement normal de ne du coup ne pas
accepter les conclusions de la vidéo
présente si on n'accepte pas les
prémices d'ailleurs moi personnellement
je n'accepte pas
ces prémices en tout cas pas entièrement
puisque pour moi il ya d'autres choses
qui sont importantes
il n'y a pas que vous sauvez du
changement climatique par exemple le
fait que la plupart des humains aille
bien et vise bien à quelque chose que je
trouve également important et qui ne
rentrent pas dans le cadre de la vidéo
précédente
l'intérêt de la vidéo précédente n'était
pas de présenter une idéologie mais
d'essayer de vraiment de se rendre
compte qu aujourd'hui
l'ia de youtube est vraiment un truc
déterminant qui va pouvoir avoir un
effet global potentiellement ultra
bénéfique et aujourd'hui dans le monde
actuel qui a des conséquences qui sont
ultra pas bénéfique
en effet si on garde lire de youtube
telle qu'elle est aujourd'hui c'est de
continuer à maximiser la rétention des
utilisateurs et idem sur twitter ou
facebook et ainsi de suite
comme l'expliquent très bien triste ans
à risque on va voir des systèmes
informatiques qui vont exploiter autant
que possible les failles psychologiques
et des utilisateurs et notamment créé
énormément d'addictions chaise
utilisateurs en promouvant les sujets
qui sont les plus vivants à savoir les
sujets qui cause notamment beaucoup de
colère et d'énervement d'indignation et
ainsi de suite
ou qu énormément de commentaires très
énervé suite vidéo précédente ça sur
youtube ou sur twitter avec des messages
dans la forme était énormément en pleine
de sarcasme d'exagération voire
d'insultés également faut bien voir
qu'il s'agit d'un sujet un petit peu
politisés donc forcément
un petit peu tous envie d'avoir de
prendre la parole et de dire ce qu'on
pense et on a tendance aussi à être pas
mal un excès de confiance c'est-à-dire à
penser que nous on a raison et que tout
le monde tout le reste
à tort et c'est justement là qu'il faut
faire super attention à éviter un
maximum le sarcasme l'exagération le
manque de charité interprétative
justement l'un qu'il faut vraiment faire
gaffe à essayer de bien débattre et
malheureusement c'était quelque chose
que qui n'est pas acquis ne transpire
pas dire dans les commentaires de la
vidéo précédente
et du coup quand on lis des commentaires
comme ça il est très tentant de penser
que du coup la plupart des gens sont
contre la vidéo et c'est très important
de sentons qu'il ya un énorme biais de
sélection
simplement parce que les gens qui
commandent sont des personnes qui sont
beaucoup plus énervés et du coup que les
commentaires de la vidéo précédente
reflète un niveau d'énervement qui est
pas représentatif de la plupart des
viewers alors c'est pour ça que
d'habitude j'ai tendance à supprimer les
commentaires qui sont excessifs comme ça
on l'a joué à dire que la vidéo
précédente c'est parti tellement vite en
plus lundi soir j'étais occupée c'est
très très vite et du coup je n'ai pas le
courage de me plonger dans les
commentaires et de supprimer les
commentaires qui est dans la forme était
très problématique mais ce qui est
intéressant de voir c'est de regarder
les sondages que du coup j'ai proposé à
la fois sur youtube et sur twitter où il
ya eu des centaines de réponses
comme des milliers assure du dehors j'ai
en tout cas d'après ces sondages
en fait la majorité des gens qui me
suivent depuis qu'ils ont répondu à ce
sondage
en fait semble assez d'accord avec
l'idée que rendre l'ia de youtube
bénéfique et finalement quelque chose
d'assez souhaitable donc c'est important
que cette voie qui n'est pas que ce
n'est pas amplifiée dans les
commentaires soit tout de même écouter
et qu'on prenne soin ne pas juste
écouter les personnes qui sont les plus
loquaces et les plus virulentes
notamment sur les réseaux sociaux
donc quand vous critiquez les idées de
la vidéo d'abord critique et bien les
idées de la vidéo est pas la conclusion
de la vidéo
l'argument est beaucoup plus important
que la conclusion de la vidéo précédente
et quand vous critiquez la vidéo c'est
assez erroné de vouloir me critiquer
mois ou avoir des attaques ad hominem
puisque finalement c'est assez
représentatifs de la majorité des viewer
et surtout encore le voit c'est les
idées qui comptent pas par moi
personnellement typiquement un bon
commentaire le commentaire de rilke arte
qui exprime son désaccord mais le fait
de façon très très poli et très claires
qui donnent envie d'être lu tout
simplement et qui fait davantage mieux
poser le débat est plus réfléchir
puisque dans ce commentaire il tarde
notamment identifie vraiment le point
clé de l'argument de la vidéo présidente
qui est vraiment cette opposition entre
la proche des ontologies qu est la
proche conséquentialiste de dire que à
quel point les conséquences importe où
est-ce qu'il faut absolument conserver
des principes déontologiques important
et militaires conclus que pour lui les
principes déontologiques sont très
importants ça c'est vraiment l'argument
convaincant contre la vidéo précédente
toutefois je mets en avant pour dire que
ça c'est la bonne manière de critiquer
la vidéo précédente
toutes les autres manière plus agressive
avec des arguments qui pourra sont pas
la vidéo aux arguments de la vidéo
précédente
passées les commentaires que j'aurais
aimé avoir supprimé mais le courage de
les supprimer parce que ça met en avant
des idées qui ne correspondent
absolument pas à la vidéo précédente et
qui en plus ont tendance à favoriser
cette indignation à cette colère qui ne
me semble pas du tout souhaitable en
tous cas dans des concerts de vidéos
cette forêt enfin à l'instar de thomas
martin il ya énormément de réflexion sur
même si on avait cette ia robustement
buzz bénéfique
est-ce que
youtube implémente résadia ce qu'il
serait possible de convaincre les tubes
d'implémenter s'étirait il s'agit une
question extrêmement difficile et en
gros je vais répondre je sais pas mais
ne semble pas improbable qui finissent
par l'accepter il ya pas mal de
mouvements chez google pour essayer de
rendre l'ia bénéfique notamment des
déclarations du pdg des publications de
google dit mind ou encore le refus des
ingénieurs de google de travailler sur
des armes autonome donc les gens qui
travaillent à google ne sont pas des
monstres flou complètement emprisonner
des incentive parce que finalement
google est une entreprise en situation
de monopole et une situation de monopole
ça pose évidemment énormément de
problèmes mais ça a également l'avantagé
qu'ils me à moins de compétition mais
qui a du coup plus de marge de manoeuvre
notamment pour des considérations
notamment éthiques
le gros problème c'est que c'est très
compliqué d'aller voir google leur dire
qu'il faut rendre mozilla bénéfique si
on ne propose pas de façon d'y arriver
sachant que le premier très difficile en
tant que tel moi personnellement je n'ai
pas confiance en les ingénieurs de
google et de youtube mêmes chercheurs de
google et de youtube pour y arriver je
pense que c'est un poème qui est très
très très difficile
il faut vraiment des années de recherche
de très haut niveau par des tops
chercheurs de tous les domaines de parce
que c'est une question légale entre est
interdisciplinaire pour pouvoir en
arriver à concevoir unir robustement
bénéfique et du coup tant qu'on n'a pas
de bonnes solutions pour rendre les ir
robustement bénéfique me semble assez
illusoire d'espérer que youtube les
imprimantes c'est pour ça que je pense
qu'aujourd'hui la priorité si vous
voulez faire du bien dans pour
l'humanité c'est vraiment de travailler
sur rendre les ia robustement bénéfique
et pour cela il est indispensable de
comprendre au moins quelques rudiments
de l'intelligence artificielle mais pas
que c'est un sujet extrêmement
interdisciplinaire et je pense que
beaucoup de gens qui ne viennent pas du
monde intime ans artificielle peuvent
grandement contribuer à rendre les ja
plus bénéfique pour ça il ya peu de
temps mais ya pas mal de réflexion
autour de problèmes économiques de
problèmes psychologiques ou encore des
problèmes sociologiques et puis bien sûr
il ya toute la partie mathématiques
également très importante bien sûr
consolider ainsi que beaucoup de
programmation et de tests qui vont être
nécessaires
bref c'est un énorme énorme énorme
chantier et le gros problème aujourd'hui
c'est que c'est un chantier sur lequel
personne de travail
virtuellement personnes au travail il y
a dans le monde moins de 100 personnes
qui travaillent sur ce problème et ja
même beaucoup beaucoup moins que 100
personnes qui me semble vraiment
attaquer le problème tel qu'il devrait
être l'attaqué donc je pense qu'il ya
besoin de beaucoup beaucoup plus de gens
qui s'intéressent à toutes ces questions
l'un des très gros problème c'est que ce
champ de recherche rendre lié à
bénéfique et quelque chose qui manque de
respectabilité c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui beaucoup de gens se
complaisent à moquer les efforts à
rendre l'ia bénéfique
du coup comme le domaine est très
mauvais il n'attire absolument pas ni le
financement ni les talents mathématiques
et autres et du coup on est vraiment
dans une impasse aujourd'hui où le truc
qui vous semble ultra prioritaire est
quelque chose qui me semble également
complètement négligé bref prendre lié à
bénéfique
ça me semble en fait aujourd'hui est
vraiment la priorité numéro un et c'est
un défi extrêmement difficile qui va
demander énormément de financement et de
réflexion posée réfléchie et énormément
de travail collaboratif par énormément
de talent avec des bagues aux différents
et j'espère que vous avez aimé cette
vidéo que ça va vous faire beaucoup
beaucoup réfléchir en fait ça on le truc
conclusion un peu de cette vidéo c'est
que si je voulais faire une bonne action
s'il vous plaît allez lire l'article que
j'ai écrit ça va vous faire normalement
beaucoup cogité et changer beaucoup de
choses par rapport à la manière dont
vous pensez le monde qui nous entoure et
surtout si vous avez les capacités
mathématiques pour y arriver vraiment
aller voir cet article s'il vous plaît
réfléchissez à ces problèmes ça me
semble vraiment urgent aujourd'hui
par ailleurs j'ai les deux nouvelles une
bonne nouvelle et une mauvaise nouvelle
la bonne nouvelle c'est que l'arctique
en fait une autre version de cet article
que j'ai travaillé pour europe 1 a été
acceptée un workshop un triplé ya qu une
des grandes conférences en évidence
artificiel donc je vais pouvoir parler
de ça à d'autres personnes intéressées
par ce sujet très excité à cette idée et
j'espère que ça va donner beaucoup de
réflexion intéressante pour améliorer ce
prêt pied et faire en sorte que ces
idées de rendre lié à bénéfique soit en
dessous claire et plus convaincante et
soit aussi plus pertinente mais cette
bonne nouvelle vient également avec une
mauvaise nouvelle puisque
france à lui à hawaii un janvier du coup
je vais être obligée d'aller à hawaï et
comme beaucoup de décalage horaire je
construisais ya les semaines avant pour
me préparer pour la confiance et a
conscience de tout ça s'est fait de plus
en janvier risque de pas trop avoir des
idées mais il reste encore un dernier
épisode de cette série sur
l'intelligence artificielle qui
exceptionnellement sortira non pas lundi
prochain mais mercredi 10 nov
parce qu'une petite surprise vous verrez
mercredi 19 et ça parlera de l'ia de
nouveaux noms notamment la probabilité
qu'ils sont de non négligeable du nid à
deux niveaux humain dans un futur pas si
éloigné si vous avez aimez cette vidéo
pensez à la laquelle a commenté à la
partie des français les abonnés pour
l'épisode merci au type harper dont
j'espère que vous serez là la prochaine
fois une fois qu'on a ces données on
peut créer des algorithmes qui me
connaîtront mieux que je ne me connais
moi-même et au final c'est pas vraiment
très compliqué car les êtres humains
sont vraiment nuls à savoir qui ils sont
[Musique]
c'est une longue balle